pour vous oui c'est une erreur c'est une
erreur mais comme cette réforme de la PJ
itinéraire c'est une erreur sur le fond
puisque ce sont des gens qui s'occupent
de faire de criminalité organisée
criminalité complexe qui ont besoin de
temps et ont finalement on risque les
affecter à la délinquance du quotidien
de leur faire faire autre chose que ce
qu'ils savent faire une question pour
vous là
oui justement comment est-ce qu'on
apporte selon vous une réponse
notamment à Marseille où on voit bien
cette criminalité organisée comment
est-ce qu'on fait dès lors que cette
réforme sera mise en place à l'horizon
2023 est-ce qu'on ne va pas perdre cette
spécificité de la police judiciaire pour
affronter ces trafics de stupéfiants par
exemple si moi je pense que que la
question telle que vous la posez et bien
posée on risque avec la réforme de
perdre des vrais pros de l'enquête au
fond sur le temps long et la pression du
quotidien pour la petite et moyenne
délinquance elle finira à s'imposer et
tôt ou tard les ddpn les fameux
directeurs départementaux de la police
nationale finiront par dire aux
enquêteurs de la PJ bon les gars je sais
que vous avez des trucs sur le feu mais
là l'urgence c'est c'est la petite
criminalité donc c'est une mauvaise idée
on sait qu'il y a une désinfection pour
l'investigation pour la filière
investigation pour la police judiciaire
on qu'on manque de moyens mais c'est
précisément parce qu'on manque de moyens
qu'il faut pas utiliser ses compétences
qui sont trop rares pour aller les
mettre dans un pot commun ou finalement
c'est bon professionnel se réutiliser à
autre chose que l'investigation que le
travail au long cours et puis elle
risque politique quand François Melun
quand les procureurs conférence des
procureurs
l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats la
conférence des barreaux la procureur de
Paris disent qu'ils sont inquiets de
cette réforme c'est quand même qui a une
forme d'entêtement chez le ministre de
l'Intérieur à vouloir persévérer chez
lui chez le directeur de la police
nationale et on comprend pas bien
pourquoi on en arrive à cette extrémité
ou Bordeaux Rennes Toulouse Angers sont
aujourd'hui dans le refus d'opérer les
opérations du quotidien c'est quand même
rare dans la police puisque vous parlez
de la justice vous étonnez du silence
des règles du pont Moretti sur ce sujet
d'un côté qu'il peut parler sur contre
une réforme défendue par Gérald Darmanin
il y a eu une des séances du beau de la
sécurité qui est intéressante j'ai
assisté pour le Sénat où on avait
Eric Dupont-Moretti et Gérald Darmanin
qui l'invitait je crois effectivement
que on travaille pas suffisamment main
dans la main entre l'intérieur et la
justice et chaque fois on se renvoie la
patate chaude
plus exactement on accable la justice
sont incompétence c'est un peu ce qui
renvoyait le message général alors même
qu'il y a une chaîne d'ailleurs on parle
de chaîne police justice de chaîne
pénale et je pense qu'effectivement il
faudrait travailler de concert alors
peut-être que
Eric Dupond-Moretti a d'autres
actualités qui
retiennent son attention mais mais je
pense à exercer correctement sa mission
pour vous non mais je pense que le on
aurait aimé effectivement que que tout
ça soit mieux piloté mais ça renvoie ce
qu'on se dit tout à l'heure en début
d'entretien il y a quand même un
sentiment de flou dans la période dans
la gestion des affaires du pays géraldar
Manin il a défendu évidemment sa réforme
hier dans le Parisien mais il semble
fléchir légèrement sur la date il parle
maintenant d'un second semestre 2023
alors qu'avant il disait courant 2023
c'est un premier pas pour vous oui
envoyer un courrier hier qui qui prend
cet élément de calendrier
il commence à envisager une forme de
négociation mieux vaut tard que jamais
mais c'est quand même un peu tard
Guilhem
[Musique]